uh Sunday morning and again, you know,
thanks for coming out today. I know it's
uh you know, kind of early for some of
you guys and uh it's not always easy to
uh find the time on a Sunday morning to
come out, but I just wanted to take uh
you know, a little bit of your Sunday
morning to talk to you today about this
new tool that we've been working on over
the summer. You know, I've been pretty
quiet over the summer, uh, for the most
part as far as, uh, posting videos on
YouTube and, uh, the weekly sessions.
You know, we took off. I had a busy
summer, but one of the things that we
were working on, um, during the summer
is this, uh, tool called the Vshift
uh, indicator, and it's available for
uh, Ninja Trader 8, and it's still uh,
you know, it's one of those that in my
opinion is uh, quite uh, quite amazing
what it does. Um it's a technical order
flowbased indicator designed to identify
and signal changes in market volatility.
Um it detects when trading environments
transition from stable uh you know which
is balance conditions to periods of
heightened activity which often
accompany breakouts, trends or
expansions away from previously balanced
market zones. Basically what it does is
going to uh track the degree of price or
orderflow volatility um that's taking
place in the market. So in other words,
how much prices are fluctuating versus
recent baseline behavior, right? Because
you know, volatility helps drive the
market. It's what causes the market to
uh, you know, make long big beautiful uh
trends that, you know, as traders,
that's really what you want to jump in
on, right? When you see a trend
occurring,
you want to get in on it as ideally as
as soon as possible, right? rather than
um you know waiting until the trend is
done. So what it does is uh the ball
shift indicator detects volatility
shifts by comparing different volatility
measurements. Um you know these are
proprietary measurements. So you know if
you ask me probably not going to share
them with you because you know I I know
people get this get these tools and then
uh you know copy them and rename them
something else. Um but
you know you know that with uh my tools
you know they they really read the order
flow. So spotting market transitions um
you know often coincides with price
moving away from areas of consolidation
balance or perceived fair value right
thus flagging potential breakouts or one
moves before they unfold. Um we'll take
a look at charts in a second but I just
want to go through some uh
uh you know some of the basics of the uh
vol shift indicator and again it it
order analyzes order flow and market
volatility. I mean it's it's one thing
to analyze order flow then it's another
thing to analyze the volatility in the
market ideally you know if you can
combine the two
when the order flow is tipping off um
something taking place in the volatility
right because what what is volatility
it's the the market basically searching
for areas where it can transact more
volume right you see these big bars
coming into the market um you know heavy
volume etc you know ideally you want to
get in on those bars cars be before they
take place. Okay. So what it does is it
senses when a market transitions from
consolidation to expansion. So it uses
its own comparisons of price movement,
volume behavior invatility to tell you
when the market is asleep. You know,
that's the low volatility, high balance.
You know, obviously there's not going to
be any signals there, but when it's
waking up, this is when the signals come
in. You know, it's the rising
volatility, expanding imbalance. The VA
inv shift basically stands for volume
plus volatility. It's not just one or
the other. Okay, it looks at both.
And
really quick,
settings are very simple. All right,
we've narrowed it down. The the two
settings that you're going to use are
volume or the V shift level between one
and three. And why is there three
different levels? Well, there's, you
know, in the market there's basically
two main participants, right? Retail
traders, institutional traders, retail
participants, institutional
participants.
And
what who drives the market the most?
Well, obviously institutional
participants, retail participants like
to uh sort of jump on the coattails
ideally of the institutional
participants.
um one to three is sort of that range,
you know, the the blending of the both.
Okay? And it's explained in the user
guide. And the other one that you're
going to deal with is uh auction skew.
Right? Now, what is an auction skew?
Right? That's that's going to be a new
phrase for a lot of people. And
basically what it does is it tells you
how fairly volume is being distributed
um in the two-way auction when it's
trading. Okay? Because you know not all
volume is created equal, right? We think
that oh you know hey this market traded
uh 200 contracts at this price level.
Well how did it transact that volume at
that price level?
You know obviously was it on the bid?
Was it on the offer in relationship to
the bar itself? Okay because it's one
thing just to have volume traded but you
know that's the whole point of order
flow is analyzing how that volume is
being traded. Now, you don't have to
worry about the there's a couple other
settings on here. Uh momentum strength
is pretty common one in my indicators.
Enable PC movement. Um obviously the
swing filter. We took the zone placement
and we've made it uh a little bit
not say more advanced, but uh we put a
twist on it in this uh version. This uh
enable golden bar. You don't have to
worry about that uh indicator. We've I'm
actually going to remove that in the
next version. Um it's something that's
already been incorporated into the
regular signals. All right. So, let's
take a look at um the charts. Again, I I
I don't want to not trying to make this
like a whole big long thing that's going
to last for hours today, but
really simple, right? You look at a
chart, right? A footprint chart, right?
And you want to analyze it. And
there's a lot of different moving parts
in a footprint chart, right? Obviously,
you got volume, right? Which is
something that, you know, most order
flow analysts
um focus on, right? You got to look at
the volume, right? Then from that
volume, you get uh secondary numbers
like uh point uh sorry uh delta um you
know points of control. You even got
value areas, you know, and then you get
imbalances in a bar. Okay. But while
you're looking at things like, you know,
the volume, the delta, the the point of
control, etc.,
you don't want to just take it in a
vacuum, right? Where you're just
analyzing it by itself,
right? What you need to do is you need
to put it in relation to how previous
bars have been trading, right? Has the
market been quiet?
If it has, how is this current bar
trading in relationship to the previous
bars when the market's been quiet?
Obviously, if the market starts picking
up in volatility, starts picking up in
volume, you know something is up. And
and how do you measure
that? Well, that's what the V shift
does, right? It it takes all that
information that you're seeing, not just
in the current bar, but relative to
previous bars, how the market has been
trading, and it's looking for those
pickups in volatility and volume. It's
not just about saying, oh, you know,
volume jumped, okay, so that that's got
to be bullish. Well, volume jumped. How
is it jumping? How, you know, that
that's where like the auction skew comes
in. How is the volume being distributed?
Right? Because every bar is going to
have volume, right? I mean, that's what
the market is is people trading, right?
People bidding, people offering, um, you
know, people buying and selling at the
market.
But from those from that trading,
sometimes, you know, there's signs
that's pretty clear of what's actually
taking place in the market. you know,
maybe there's um you know, strong
institutional participation coming in
and you know, is is building a position
or you have a combination of
institutional and retail participation
coming in to the market. And
if you're just looking at one particular
thing in the order flow, the volume or
the delta, you know, you you're going to
be at a slight
disadvantage.
So that's why we created the V shift
because you know that I I I noticed that
when you know talking to traders um you
know discussing how their trading is
going you know what what their um you
know sort of their blind spots are is is
literally when it comes down to
analyzing um volume and volatility in
relation
to how the market is currently trading.
Right? I mean
bars and movements don't happen in a
vacuum.
It's related to what's just took place
in the market, right? And then that's
the beauty of orderflow is being able to
take that information
and use it to form your analysis to give
you um buy signals, sell signals in the
market. Okay. So, you know what you're
looking at here, all right, with point
of control with the volume, um, etc.,
you can wrap all that up into a nice
little indicator, which we did in the
ball shift indicator. Now, the ball
shift indicator, again, it reads the
order flow. You don't need to use a
footprint chart. I'll show you on a
normal um, bar chart how it works as
well. Now, again, like I said, so you
add it to the chart. really simple.
Whether you're using a footprint or
you're using a
um candlestick chart, it's the same.
Just make sure you have tick replay on.
Um
so, just really simple, go run through
some of these settings. Multi-time frame
analysis. I'll show you how, you know,
what type of markets you'd want to use
that in. Um I've always said that order
flow is best used, um you know, as soon
as the information is available.
However, some markets like interest
rates, you know, if you're using a
timebased chart like a one minute chart,
it's going to be hard to get uh
any solid information in the order flow
simply because it trades a lot on the
bid and the offer over a one minute
period. So, you sort of have to expand
that out. But, I'll show you trade entry
signal. Now, we got a slightly different
setting on here. We use uh it's got to
just move one tick
over the next five bars. Again, you can
you my my programmer was playing around
with that and he left it in as one and
five. Normally I use two and two. Um the
visuals are still the same as you know a
lot of our other tools until tested or
fixed right here. And again, you know, I
like to use until tested. I'm a visual
person. And you have things like uh
signal box high, signal box low, you
know, where it appears on the bar. Uh,
we do have a slightly different setting
down here under zone placement. Bar
direction. You could have it, you know,
at the top of the bar, which would be
bar direction if it's bullish. Um, at
the bottom of the bar if you want
instead, or you could have both the top
and the bottom of the bar. And I'll show
you, but like I said, the main settings,
ball level ones through three, you know,
one is is where you should start.
Enable auction skew. Uh, right now it's
disabled. I'll show you how it looks
when it's enabled. Momentum strength I
like to keep at three. Enable PLC
movement. Um, you know, you can turn
that on. Um, if you're using enable PC
movement, you're probably not going to
use uh swing filter with it just because
they they sort of go in the opposite
direction. Um, you got momentum strength
on and PC movement, which would sort of
negate a swing filter in the sense of,
you know, swing filters designed to find
swing highs and swing lows. um for
reversal trades. So if you have momentum
on, it's pointless to use a swing
filter. Okay. Then you know there's a
sound as well. Um then just the normal
settings data series setup visuals which
is just how it's plotted on the chart
and obviously the actual plots
themselves.
Um
down in here, you know, buy signal is uh
blue triangle up, sell signal is red,
triangle down.
Okay. So, you can see the sign the
bullish signal coming in here, here,
here, here. Now, you'll notice I have
these um zones being drawn out from the
top of the bar.
But let me just talk about that for a
second here.
Normally way we would draw out
the zones, okay, is what we call there's
two types. You can have both three
types. Bar direction, which is what you
see here, meaning if it's bullish, it'll
draw it out at the top of the bar. Um,
opposite direction, which is sort of the
the most common one that we use in our
indicators, meaning if it's a green up
candle, the signal, sorry, the zone will
start drawing out from the bottom of the
bar.
Okay. Now, how we're going to use that
is right, you can use them when you say
opposite direction, you're going to use
it as stops. You can see the bullish
signal, bullish signal, bullish signal.
The triangle is the actual signal that
that just affects the zones. Okay.
Now, let me just uh this is with the
trade entry signal
on. Okay, let me just move this up here.
So, if I take it off, right, so the
trade entry signal, right, the whole
point of the trade entry signal, right,
I got one, it's got to move one tick
within the next five bars. Okay, so for
example,
there is a signal here being formed, a
bearish signal, but since the next bar
didn't go down, it's not giving you the
bearish signal, right? It didn't move in
the next five bars one tick lower than
the low here. Okay, so that's why I like
to use the trade entry signal. So you
see here's a bullish signal, bullish
signal, bullish signal here. Okay,
another bullish here and then the
bearish ones come in right here.
Now,
if you have trade entry signal turned
off,
right? So, you're going to see that one
bearish signal
coming in right here. If you can see it,
but it's coming in right here. So
basically you know trade entry signal
looks for that follow-th through order
flow. Okay.
Now
again
all levels the main setting you should
always start at
uh one. The next level is two. So it's
some of the signals might change a
little bit. you might get uh you know as
you go up with the ball level between
one and three being the highest
most strictest you're going to get less
signals. Okay. So you can see all right
you got a signal coming in here still
got the signal
here
right so you can see you know signals
going down here signal here
you know signal here signal here signal
here this is when it's set at two
right when you set it at three you're
going to get slightly fewer signals okay
because it's taking in other aspects of
not other aspects but it's filtering out
some things in the order flow that's why
you don't see a signal here when there
was one earlier okay um
you know so you still see a few signals
coming in there now
you know this is eurourrency if you're
looking at uh something like e- minis
you know same thing now auction skew
right deals with how volume is being
distributed
within the bar.
So you enable it, right? You see there's
no sell signals there. Still the one
here. You still got the buys coming in
here. Um you don't have the other
further buys that came in here. Okay.
Now, you know, sometimes it's a little
bit easier to see it on a bar chart. So,
let's just um
yeah, we'll pull up uh I don't know,
pull up E- Minis. See if I got a simple
bar chart here. Candlestick white.
We got tick replay on. Yeah, tick replay
is on. And
we'll just add it
here again. You know, let's keep it
simple. Hang
on here.
Hang on a second, guys.
Uh sorry about that guys. Um so here all
right so this is e- minis
on Friday now
again trade entry signals on right ball
level set to one PC movement is on. So
you can see here, let me just make this
smaller.
You know, one versus three. Okay, these
are the main settings.
Let's give it a second.
All
right. So, you see some the signals how
they've
gone away. All right. But so you still
got the main signal even though you have
the zones drawn out. All right. The
you know, these bearish zones, right?
You don't have the actual signal.
Really, what you're looking at is the
triangle. Okay, that's telling you what
you're seeing here was a potentially
bullish
ball shift taking place, right? And it
looks like it's about to to break out,
but it doesn't, right? That's why cuz
that's where using the trade entry
signal is going to help you because the
fact that there's no follow-through
coming in here
or here or here, you know, those are
those false breakouts that a lot of
traders fall into, right? That that's
where using the trade entry signal is
going to help you a lot. Here, here,
here. Because if I have the trade entry
signal uh disabled here,
right? What you're going to see now is
you're going to see a buy signal, a buy
signal, a buy signal, you know, here,
here. I think the other one was here,
right? Which is, you know, why do you
want to take trades that aren't going to
work out? And people say, well, you
know, if well, if you know, these
indicators are so great, you know, why
you got to use that? Well, what's taking
place here, right? we're going sideways
and now you're sort of getting the you
know it's it's like those uh you know
you see the shows the guy's in the
hospital and then he goes flatlined
right this is like oh he's got a
heartbeat coming in that's that's like
your heartbeat your heartbeat but even
though these trades don't don't work out
right that's where the trade entry
signal is going to help you right
because again you know sometimes you
know things are building for a move
but often times you have
you know that extra RA what do you call
I don't know what you want to call it
that um not layer but when you have
institutional participants and
institutional participants is a wide
umbrella it covers you know obviously
the HFTs even though um
you know when you think of HFTs you
think of market makers um you know the
real money the hedge funds the CTAs etc
it it really covers a lot um
that's taking place here, right? Taking
place here, taking place here, but the
market doesn't um follow through. That's
where using the trade entry signal is
going to help you. It's going to keep
you in on
the the strong moves. Okay. So, let's go
back to turn on the trade entry signal.
Keep this on on one here.
Okay, just give it a second here because
it, you know, when you you have it on
your chart since, you know, when you're
running on on tick replay on historical
data, um it does matter how much data
you have, you know, that you're trying
to read. So imagine right again you know
trade entry signal you know one two
well now this is set at uh one so it's a
little bit lower but look at it you know
one two trades
that you're not taking right and it's
keeping you sort of short in here. This
one is sort of break even but you're
catching this move. Now let's talk about
something else. The um auction skew.
Okay. Again, auction skew is going to
measure how
volume is being distributed in that bar.
Okay? Because again, not all volume that
trades is equal,
right? It could be skewed one way or the
other, bullish or bearish or it can be
equal as well. Okay? And by enabling
auction skew, what that helps you to do
um is is I'll say cleans up the chart,
but you know, you see now instead of a
lot of signals, you've got basically
just the one here at 8:49
um and a couple here where we're going
sideways on Friday afternoon. But it's
something that, you know, depending on
the market. So, you know, if we changed
markets,
uh, I don't know. I don't want to use an
equity, but we'll we'll we'll try MNQ.
Okay.
Just sort of scrunch it up. It might
take a second or two longer for this
chart to come up because I haven't
loaded the indicator on here today. You
know, one thing I've noticed with Ninja
Trader is if you have a chart already
open
with the data coming in and when you add
the indic any indicator on it, it just
seems faster. Um
now
you know all markets trade differently
in a sense even though you know they all
follow the order flow but you know
markets like E- Minis, MNQ, NQ,
uh crude oil, gold
in a bar, like if you're on a timebased
bar, there's usually enough information
that if you're looking at the order
flow, you know, whether it's a footprint
or whether it's um you know an indicator
like V shift there's enough information
in that bar itself but when you're
looking at a market like
um you know bonds or ultra bonds or or
10 or ultra 10s fives
using the multi-time frame which I'll
get into next is going to be a big help.
So you can see here right this is with
the auction skew turned on right so you
got you know in the morning you got a
nice little bearish signal coming in
here another bearish here right when the
cash opened you know we're trading you
know basically 880 23 880 you know right
for 100 point drop you know nice bullish
signal there um but that's the auction
skew but what I want to talk about now
we we'll take a look at uh
yeah I don't know ultra bonds Okay,
because I know a lot of you guys have
been moving into ultra bonds. And let's
just uh clean this up here. We'll turn
off auction skew.
You'll see movement now. Again, mall
level set to one.
Okay, so that was Friday. This was the
day before,
right? Friday was kind of tough actually
in the interest rates. You know, there's
a little bit of a move here. Looked like
it was going to break out, go higher. I
mean, there's some bearish information
and then it just sold off. Didn't give a
signal there, but you know, the day
before, nice, beautiful move down. You
know, the day before catching this nice
move up, nice move up there. You know,
the day before and catches that move
there. Um, but that's ultra bonds. It's
a bit more volatile than say bonds. But
if you go look at bonds.
Okay. Now again this is with auction
skew set to
sorry
the um v level set to one. If I had it
on three
which is you know the highest you can go
right this how it looks. This is again
this is just a one minute chart. But
when you start enabling something like
PC movement,
right, you got just one signal there.
Okay, you know, PC movement, you know,
the day before no signal, day before
one, two signals. PLC movement takes
into account more of the volume. So, how
you going to get sort of around it?
Well, if you're not if you like to use
PLC movement and you're trading bonds,
you're not getting enough um necessarily
information So what you do is you make
you sort of widen the net, right? The
the time that the order flow analysis is
taking place. So you could change it to
like a threeminut chart, the analysis,
even though your underlying chart
is still on a one minute chart. Okay?
And generally speaking, it should give
you some more
more signals. Okay? ultra bonds here
or sorry not less signals but you know
signals when the market is a bit oh
quieter there you got a nice little sell
signal there
you know here
you know if you were in you know
something like the euro currencies you
could use the multi- time frame analysis
here right you're seeing three minute
chart Start right ball level set to
three. PC there is enabled. You know if
you had it at one.
I see some more signals coming in.
All right. Bar direction.
Now this is where it gets interesting.
Okay.
So let's just go back to
Yeah. And again, you could use whatever
you want. Say you want to look at it
based off of a eight range chart, the
signals,
you know, on your one minute chart, you
can do that, right? So, you just change
the range. Um, you know, say you you
could even go shorter time frame, 30
seconds,
right? So, say you're losing a one
minute chart, but you want to, you know,
I say get ahead of everybody, but use a
30 second underlying chart for signals,
you can do that.
Okay?
You know, tick chart, you know, whatever
100 tick
with the signals.
Again, you know, we've we've added that
because I know that, you know, people
sometimes they find some nice settings
on a different type of chart, but
they're stuck with trading, you know, a
timebased chart simply because that's
the market that their other indicators
work on. Um, maybe it doesn't work so
well on a tick chart that maybe they got
some other way of analyzing the market
on a timebased chart, but they like how
the signals appear on say uh, you know,
a 100 tick chart or a 50 tick chart and
they want to plot them there. So, that's
how you could use it.
Now
zone placement is bar direction is
opposite direction. So for opposite
direction it's the normal way. It's at
the bottom of the bar if it's a bullish.
It's at the top of the bar if it's
bearish. That would act as your support
resistance.
But we also have a feature here you
could add both. Okay? And I'll show you
why you want to use this.
So let me just get here.
Okay. So, just expand it up here.
There are traders
that like to see when there were signals
from earlier,
right? Like there was you can see um you
know here there's a couple there was a
bullish signal that came in here a
bullish signal that came in here but you
didn't have the follow through come here
but they like to have the zone drawn out
to sort of see where hey you know what
there was a level you know there was
earlier at when the market got up to
this level
now we're trading back here and the
volatility is picking up again. So when
we reached a level earlier there was
volatility picking up but it didn't
there was no followth through. So what
they want to see is you know when the
market comes back to a certain level if
there's that same volatility. I'm not
advocating that you know you you trade
like the failed signal you know with a
buy stop getting long here. Um but I
just want to give you guys some you know
an explanation on why we draw it out. um
both ways and because you know like you
have it was trying to break out here, it
was trying to break out here and finally
it broke out here, right? And then that
was it. It was off to the races, right?
If you were trading sort of these levels
where they're coming in back to back. Um
you know, you could look at an argument
there. Okay?
You know, you could see even on the
bearish ones, right?
But it's interesting how, you know, when
there was the volatility came in, how
you often see it can stop at that level
and reverse. I mean, there's other times
it just blows right through. So, it is
an option for you guys if you want to
use that.
All right. So,
hang on here. I'm taking a look at some
of these questions here.
One asks
the okay this is a standalone indicator.
This is not part of overflows trader
itself.
Okay. And it's not going to be part of
order flow trader. Um there's too much
that goes into it to to add it in there.
Um
yeah, Luis,
this is being recorded. Um so if you
missed the beginning, um you you'll get
it. Abby, I see your question there
about your license token. Um,
just really quick guys,
hang on here.
I'll send you a new license token. But
yeah, there there is a link because this
runs because this deals also with this
indicator.
There's a link. So you know on this
indicator and you know majority of our
other indicators they have the license
token which drops in here right you just
need to enter it once if you have a
system upgrade you know BIOS upgrade
Windows upgrade um what that does oftent
times is it causes Ninja Trader to
create a new machine ID okay because
your license token is linked to your
machine ID
And instead of constantly sending me
emails, you have a link, right? You you
should have it. It comes with the email
um with your license token
and a download information on resetting
it. You just enter your existing license
token in there and hit reset. Okay. But
uh Abby, I'll send you um a new one
as well because maybe you don't have the
the proper link.
Now,
one thing. So, let's just go back here
real quick to um
like MNQ, okay?
You know, MQ is a very high, you know,
it's a high volatile market,
high volatility market. We everyone
knows that, you know, just the way it
moves, it's it's going back and forth,
uh, you know, shockingly. um at times
and actually I think I got NQ on here.
So what this is NQ um again this is set
at one with PC movement. Okay. So
during the day session
right MNQ obviously a lot of volatility.
What people don't realize is
these markets that are are pretty
volatile during the day, right? That
it's hard for a lot of traders to trade
during the day simply because of the
crazy price movements up and down. um
you know you find yourself getting
stopped out or on very wide stops is
during you know Asian session
European session you get nice not
controlled moves but nice like to me
normal moves right so you know you can
see you know these nice moves where it
goes you know here yeah there shorts but
it doesn't go anywhere so okay it
stopped out then you catch a nice long
move from like 2 920 to 940
right? Nice more controlled moves. Um
obviously during European session things
picked up but it's something that you
should look at because you know again
you know we spend a lot of time looking
at volatility and for a lot of traders
you know this is NASDAQ during the day
it's okay you know some you know people
are are
adrenaline junkies whereas you know
there's other type of traders that are
more reserved um
you know that just want to
enjoy trading I guess you know rather
than um you know
living and dying with each you know each
bar because you know on NASDAQ you know
you get these bars that you know 910 all
the way down to you know 880 it's a 30
point bar in one minute some people just
can't stomach that um look at it in the
night session you know Asian hours
European hours you you tend to get still
get nice moves but it's not as radical
as it is um during the day. This is
NASDAQ NQ the other day,
right? Just going back the last few
days. But you can see here, right? I
mean, yeah, it's it's nice when you
catch a move from, you know, 410 uh 240
down, you know, you know, down into 910
very fast. But for some traders, you
know, it's like that volatility back and
forth wrecks with their mind because
they're like, should I get out? Should I
stay? Whereas if you're looking at it,
you know, here, right, this is a
European session. It's basically a nice
mechanical move up followed by a nice
move down followed by a nice move up
followed by a nice move back down.
Okay? And again, you know, it takes
that everything that you see forming
here, right? I mean, here's an area
where we're going sideways, right?
Volatility starts picking up. Looks like
we're going to move lower,
but but it just wasn't to be right. Then
we start moving back up here. Um, and
again, if you have
here, trade entry signal on,
you're not even getting the signal for
that trade. You're getting the bullish
signal coming in to get long here.
So anyway guys, I'm not going to keep
you guys on. You know, it's Sunday
morning. Um,
and you know, I want you to enjoy your
weekend, but if this is something you
think you could add to your trading,
just go to uh ballshift.com,
www.vallshift.com.
I think it's it's it's going to be a
nice tool for a lot of traders to
actually take advantage of what's, you
know, the volatility and the volume in
the market. Okay, now I'm going to put
it in the chat here
because this one is, you know, we're
sort of coming out with a line of more
premium indicators
this year. We're sort of taking a, you
know, we got a lot of tools, but we're
sort of streamlining them into it. So,
just go to ballshift.com. You sort of
see here, you can still build out the
page. You have 57% off. This one's going
to be priced similar to what Orderflows
Trader is and and the toolbox uh going
forward. But for now, you get 57% off.
Um cuz we really want to make it a
standalone. You know, we're going to
plug it into uh Markers. Uh we're going
to get with uh
what's his name? Pablo. I was going to
say Patrick. It's Pablo. But markers
hopefully get a a um
a presentation showing you how to link
it up with markers. Should work with
Blood Hound. Um my programmer's uh
working on to make sure that it will
work with Blood Hound as well. All
right, so just go to ballshift.com and
you can find out more about it there.
All right, everyone take care. Um Abby,
we'll get to your uh Okay, click here.
Um
crude oil just really quick. Um, there's
a question about crude oil coming in
from Mike. Let's go to crude.
Okay. So, this is
crude. Now, again, this is with uh let's
take a look at the settings there. Set
to three
or sorry, set to one.
momentum strength set at three. Enable
PC. You know, if I turn on auction skew,
how does that
change it? So,
well, here, let's just do this
cuz sometimes, you know, people get
confused with all the zones being drawn
out. So, we'll just disable the zones
for now. Disable the zones. Put it at
zero. Okay. So you're seeing,
you know, okay, a little bearish bearish
here or some bullish little bullish
bearish bullish
bullish here. People say, "Wow, you
know, why is this signal right at this
high?" Well, it's first signal is here
as we're coming out of this
consolidation area. Here's a nice
bullish signal. It's bearish, bearish,
bullish down here. Um,
you know, even if you were to,
you know, go up to say three.
Okay.
Here. So, what do we got? Kind of
similar. So, the bullish ones, the
bearish, the bearish, the bullish here.
If you were to uh disable
auction skew. Just curious how it looks
here with without the PLC movement.
So this is just the pure wall shift
signal itself. So if you're a scalper,
say you want to, you know, I know some
traders
even look at a two or three minute
chart.
This is three minute signals,
you know.
Say you want to look at
10 range
again. That's with that three. You know,
you'll turn on the auction skew.
Yeah.
So, I mean, you'd have to play around
with it when you're getting into range
charts. Um, it does make a difference as
to what you're looking at. Um
just go with one
three
show five 135. Usually momentum strength
I like to keep at three. And you if you
really wanted to if you want to disable
it,
you'll get more signals obviously.
Um,
yeah, Hines, we'll send out a uh a link
for the recording
uh later when the recording is done. You
see here, this is set at one with
momentum strength set at zero. You'll
see movement. It's actually not bad
here.
You know, it's catching this major move
down from around 35
down here back up here again. these
moves up. Um,
have you ever will you ever have for
Trading View? She's asking if we'll ever
have indicators for Trading View. Um,
let me share something with the problem
right now with with Trading View
is
the way that it handles
the data. Um,
where is it? Here. You'd have to when
when you go deep into trading view,
let me see here.
Data
analysis, you can't look at orderflow
is what it does is it aggregates the
actual data.
Okay.
Um, we have to go to here trading view
because you can't look at the normal
scripts. Actually, you got to go into
trading view itself.
Um,
data,
but when you get into I forgot where it
was. They they have a whole thing here.
Um,
I used to be able to find it pretty
easy. Now they're just sort of burying
it here.
Let's see what it's got in here.
Volume footprints. Anything in here?
here the chart. So on the footprint,
right? This is their footprint. It's a
normal footprint, right? But this chart
type retrieves the volume's volume data
for multiple inchabar intervals.
Intervals lower than the charts. So for
example, the order in which a chart
request intraabar intervals for its
calculations is 1 second, 1 minute, 15
minutes, 60, and 1 day. Okay. So if if
you're on like
you know a one minute chart
it's going to go take it from you know
whatever 5 seconds 30 seconds as opposed
to as the volume comes in itself. So the
interval gradually increases as
available historical data becomes
exhausted starting with the lowest
available interval. In other words the
deeper into the charts history you go
the higher the intraabar interval of the
volume data. So the footprints for the
charts, recent candles are the most
precise since they're the most granular,
right? But it's the problem with that is
it's not coming in the way it does on a
Ninja Trader, go charting, um, Sierra
Charts, motive wave, where it comes in
as the trade happens. It's taking sort
of these bar intervals, 1 second, 1
minute, etc. Um, to categorize. That's
why the data that you're going to see on
the footprint differs
from Ninja Trader, from Sierra Chart,
from motive wave, from go charting
because the way that it's calculated
shouldn't be calculated. It should be
handled on a trade by trade basis.
Okay.
But um that's just one thing and and
that's the same thing I I know People
ask me about, you know, data sources.
Um,
and when you're looking at like uh
because I know a lot of people use um
interactive brokers and they ask me, can
I use the data from there? I say you
could use interactive brokers to execute
your trade, but you should get your data
from someplace else like um IQ feed or
or kinetic or CQG because
this is the same way that interactive
brokers used to handle the data. I don't
know if they still do, but um this is
why when you look at the footprint, it
is different. Um
do you have ATM settings for MNQ or ENQ
on one minute time frame? I see a lot of
entry signals. So, it's for scalping
with six to seven targets. What it
depends on your how you're trading. Um,
ATM settings
are going to vary by market. You know,
again, I know a lot of guys that trade
in Q. If you're on a one minute time
frame,
I I there's a some traders I know that
will literally trade intraar. Um,
they're just looking to ride it in and
out very fast.
um you know they're they're out before
the bar even closes. Okay. Whereas
there's other traders obviously they
want to maximize it the signal and sort
of ride it out as long as um they can
until the order flow changes. So to have
like sort of a stock answer, you know
what ATM do you recommend? Depends how
you are as a trader, right? Because
there are traders that will try to just
get 10 ticks. Well, there's other people
traders trying to get 10 points.
Obviously, if you're on, you know, these
quote combines or whatever, I don't
know, they're always changing the rules.
You know, there was a 30 second rule.
So, if you're trying to trade intra bar
and a one minute bar, um, you know, you
could be filled in 10 in 3 seconds on
NASDAQ. So, it's hard to, um, it's hard
to say. It's more of a, you know, I can
give recommendations if that's what you
want, but I don't want to say, oh, Mike
says it's this way, it has to be this,
or it has to be that.
But anyway guys, um I'm going to end it
there for today. We've gone almost an
hour, uh which is which is nice. So
again, you know, just go to
ballshifts.com, ballshift.com, not
shifts ballshift um.com if you want to
get started with this indicator. I'll
probably do another presentation like
this um
later this week if I can find figure out
which day exactly I can do it on. Uh
maybe tomorrow afternoon or something.
But uh you know we're we're still uh
we're very excited about this indicator
and again you know right now it's at 57%
off. So thanks everyone. Have a great uh
Sunday and I'll catch you guys
on the next presentation. Take care.
Um Hines asks really quick I have your
orderflow trader. Can I implement this
indicator? Yeah, it works with u
it'll sit on top of orderflow trader as
well, right? I I showed you here, right?
You see it signaling here.
All right, everyone. Take care.